or call 1-877-866-8555.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, OVER THE
WEEKEND, THE CO-OWNER OF THE
STATEN ISLAND BAR, MAX PUBLIC
HEALTH, ARRESTED FOR REFUSING TO
ABIDE THEY SAVED BY NEW YORK’S
DRACONIAN CORONAVIRUS
RESTRICTIONS.
EVERYBODY AT THIS POINT KNOWS
ABOUT MASK AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE AN APPETITE,
MORE RISK THAN OTHERS, STILL
FREEDOM IN THE COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO DANNY’S OF ATTORNEY
THE ARREST OCCURRED FOLLOWING
THE CHASE FROM SEVERAL DEPUTIES.
BY THE WAY, NOT IN UNIFORM.
ONE JUMPS ON THE HOOD OF THE CAR
IS YOU CAN SEE IN THE VIDEO.
YOU CAN SEE THEY’RE TRYING TO
STOP AND NOT DRIVE, GET THE GUY
OFF THE CAR.
HE CLAIMS THAT DEPUTIES DRESSED
IN DARK CLOTHING, NEVER IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES, CLAIM HE WAS RUNNING
FOR HIS LIFE.
IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE HE JUMPED
ON IT AS HE WAS TRYING TO GO
AWAY.
THESE ARE THE REPORTS THAT THE
DEPUTY YOU SEE IN THE VIDEO
BROKE BOTH HIS LEGS.
THIS VIDEO PROVIDED TO US BY HIS
ATTORNEYS YOU CAN SEE POLICE
PULLING HIM FROM HIS CAR.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE SHERIFF’S
OFFICE ASKING ABOUT THE DEPUTIES
INJURIES AND THEY WOULD NOT
COMMENT SAYING THE MATTER WAS
UNDER CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
HERE WITH THE LATEST, MAX PUBLIC
HOUSE CO-OWNER AND DENNY IS WITH
US WITH HIS ATTORNEY LEWIS WITH
US.
THANK YOU BOTH.
II AM LOOKING AT THIS AS A FORME
BUSBOY, COOKER, BARTENDER, I’M
LOOKING AT YOUR BUSINESS AND
YOUR GETTING KILLED.
EVERY RESTAURANT OWNER I KNOW IS
GETTING KILLED TO OPEN THEIR
DOOR TO EITHER PAY THEIR RENT OR
THEIR MORTGAGE COME UP WITH THE
LIGHTS ON, STOCK THE BAR, HIRE
THE PEOPLE.
THESE RESTRICTIONS I MEAN, DO
PEOPLE REALLY UNDERSTAND YOUR
HEARTS, LIFE AND SOUL INVOLVED
IN THIS, SIR?
>> EVERYTHING -- WE PUT
EVERYTHING INTO IT LIKE ALL
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND THAT’S
THE WHOLE REASON WHY WE STARTED
ALL THIS IS TO BRING ATTENTION
TO IT.
TO SAY WE NEED ASSISTANCE, WE
HAVE TO OPEN IN A SAFE WAY.
BUT WHAT THEY’VE BEEN DOING TO
US WAS AN ACCEPTABLE, RAKING
THIS ON FOR AS LONG AS THEY HAVE
IN CONTINUING TO DO IT.
>> Sean: I WILL GET TO THE
INCIDENT WE HAVE ON THE
VIDEOTAPE BUT LET’S BE CLEAR
HERE.
I DON’T THINK ANY AMERICAN IS
ENCOURAGEDIGNORANT TO WHAT THE R
COVID-19 ARE.
WE LEARNED ABOUT SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND MASKS AND IS IT
FAIR TO SAY WE KNOW THE RULES IF
WE WANT TO ABIDE BY THEM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IN MARCH WHEN THEY DID THE
SHUTDOWNS, NONE OF US WERE SURE
WHAT WAS GOING ON, BUT AS YOU
SAID, AT THIS POINT WE ARE ALL
ADULTS AND WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE RISK IS AND WHAT’S GOING ON.
>> Sean: YOUR LOYAL CUSTOMERS
WANT TO GO TO YOUR BAR?
I’M SURE SOMEWHERE A MASK I
MEAN, THEY ARE CHOOSING TO GO
THERE AT THIS POINT.
NOW, I ADVISE GOING DON’T GO
AROUND TO GRANDMA OR GRANDPA IF
YOU’RE EXPOSED DON’T GO AROUND
MOM AND DAD, THAT’S MY HUMBLE
ADVICE.
WHAT DO I KNOW, I’M NOT A
DOCTOR.
I WOULD ADVISE THEM TO TAKE CARE
OF OTHER PEOPLE I WOULD NOT WANT
TO GET SOMEBODY SICK.
NOW, THEY ARE CHOOSING TO GO TO
YOUR BAR KNOWING WHAT THE RISKS
ARE.
IT IS THAT A FAIR STATEMENT IN A
FREE SOCIETY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: WRITES, OKAY, HAPPEN
TO BE A FREEDOM GUY MYSELF.
INFORM PEOPLE, ENCOURAGE THEM TO
DO THE RIGHT THING.
OKAY, THE THE QUESTION IS THE
COPS WERE UNDERCOVER AND THEY
WERE IN A MARKED UNMARKED CAR.
OF >> THAT’S ABSOLUTELY TRUE,
DRESSED HIM WAS COMPLETELY IN
BLACK AND BLACK SKULL CAPS ON
AND CAME OUT FROM BETWEEN TWO
CARS AT 12:29TH, 25 YARDS AWAY
FROM DANNY BEHIND HIM.
YELLED HEY, AND STARTED CHARGING
TOWARDS HIM.
THAT WAS THE IMPETUS OF HIM
RUNNING TO HIS CAR AS YOU CAN
SEE ON THE TAPE.
>> Sean: IT REMINDS ME, YOU
KNOW WHAT’S WRONG WITH THE ERIC
GARNER CASE, WHERE THE ARRESTING
A GUY OVER A LOOSE CIGARETTE?
HOW STUPID IS THAT WITH LIMITED
POLICE RESOURCES.
OKAY, I’M SURE THEY WILL SAY
THEY DID IDENTIFY THEMSELVES, I
DON’T KNOW IF WE HAVE AUDIO AND
BACKS YOU UP.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE, THE WAY I
SAW YOU PULLING AWAY YOU’RE
TRYING TO SAY GET OUT OF THE
WAY.
YOU GO AND SLOW TO START SO
OBVIOUSLY, YOU’RE SCARED HERE
TOO, AM I WRONG IN MY
INTERPRETATION OF THAT?
>> I WAS SCARED OF THE ENTIRE
TIME.
I WAS SCARED THE ENTIRE TIME,
FROM THE ORDEAL THAT HAPPENED, I
WAS RUNNING FOR MY LIFE BECAUSE
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS HAPPENING.
AT NO POINT DID I THINK THAT
THOSE WERE SHERIFFS.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE NO IDEA WHO
THOSE GUYS ARE CHASING.
I LOVE CONSUMMATELY POLICE
SUPPORTER.
>> SO DO WE BURIED.
THESE WERE POLICE AND BLACK
CLOSE THAT IN THE POLICE
COMPLAINTS, THE POLICE COMPLAINT
IT SAYS THEY DID NOT IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES THEY JUST YELLED.
>> AND NO POINT DID THEY
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AS SHERIFFS
OR LAW ENFORCEMENT OR SHOW ANY
TYPE --
>> Sean: I DON’T KNOW IF I
SHOULD REVEAL THIS, DANYA, BUT I
KNOW COPS THAT ARE TELLING YOU
PRIVATELY, WHISPERING IN THEIR
YEAR THEY DON’T WANT TO DO IT TO
YOU.
THEY ARE BEING FORCED TO, HAVE
YOU HEARD THAT FROM COPS?
>> I’M JUST GOING TO SAY NO
COMMENT ON THAT.
>> I’M GOING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
WE’VE HEARD FROM MANY, SEAN.
OF >> Sean: THEY DON’T -- THEY
DON’T WANT TO ARREST A GUY FOR
SELLING LOOSE CIGARETTES WHEN
YOU’VE GOT GUYS SELLING HEROIN
AND FENTANYL DOWN THE BLOCK.
NOW WE’VE GOT A BILLION DOLLARS
IN CUTS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, I REALLY
SYMPATHIZE FOR YOU HAVING GROWN
UP IN THE RESTAURANT BUSINESS.
MY DAD WAS A WAITER AND I WAS A
DISHWASHER, I DID ALL THE JOBS
AND I WAS A BARTENDER.
YOU KNOW, I KIND OF ADMIRE YOUR
CUSTOMCUSTOMER BASE, THEY WANT T
SUPPORT LOCAL BUSINESSES.
WE’VE GOT TO DO BETTER THAN THIS
THIS.
WE COULD IF WE CARED TO.
THESE POLITICIANS DON’T CARE.
I’M REALLY SORRY THAT YOU’RE
GOING THROUGH ALL THIS TO BE
VERY HONEST WITH YOU.
>> SEAN, I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE
THING.
I WANT TO SAY REAL QUICK THAT AT
NO TIME THERE WAS NOBODY THAT
WROTE TOO LATE.
I WAS AN ABSOLUTE OUTRIGHT LIE
BUT THE SHERIFF’S DEPARTMENT.
THE OFFICER YOU SEE RUNNING AND
THEN VIDEO IS DID NOT BREAK HIS